So any procedure that we could write recursively. We're going to
also write without using a recursive definition. And I want to
show you another way that we might have defined is
palindrome. So here we're doing this with the for loop,
and we're looping using the variable i and the range
from 0 to the length of s divided by 2.
So that's going through halfway of s. And inside the
loop we have an if-test that checks if the character
at position i is different at the position negative i
plus 1. So that's going to be counting from the back
of the string, i's positions away. If those are different,
then we've found a mismatch and we return false. If they're
not different, we're going to keep going through the loop. Once
we get to the end of the loop without finding any
differences, we know it's a palindrome and we return true.
So this is also another way we could define is palindrome.
I think this is more complicated to understand, and harder to
get right. It took me three tries before this code worked correctly,
whereas the recursive definition, I could get right the first time.
If we wanted to test very long palindromes, this would be much
more efficient, than the code that we had with the recursive
definition. And there are a couple of reasons for that. One is
that the recursive definition keeps making new strings, every time we
do the recursive call, we have to create a new string, and
that's pretty expensive. Another reason is that the recursive calls
themselves are fairly expensive, and there are languages that make
recursive calls fairly cheap. Python is not one of them.
In Python, it's fairly expensive to do a recursive call. So
for most procedures, the recursive way is often the most
elegant, and the easiest way to get correct. If we're
really worried about performance, and we need procedures to work
on really large inputs. We're often better off trying to find
a non recursive way of defining that procedure.